えー 最初にまず で 最初にお釈迦様の言葉一つ勉強しようかなと
してみようかなということで
で 法句経の十一番と十二番目です
アサ
ーレーサーレマティーノーサーレーチャサーレダッシーノーテーサーランナディガッチャンティーニッチャーサンカッパゴーシェラーサーランチェサーレトーニャンバー
サーランチェアサーレトーテーサーランアディガッチャンティーサッマーサンカッパゴーシェラーという二つの偈なんです
で まず 皆様の手元に日本語訳あると思いますけど
日本訳にしがみつかないで
まず私の意味を理解して
それからそれ嫌だったら日本語訳にしがみついても構いません
それは自由ですけど とりあえずせっかく喋ってるんだから
今までの勉強会のやり方は違くて
もういくら喋っても絶対聞いてやらんぞという感じで
この日本語訳にしがみついてるんですね
それで誤解しちゃうと私のせいにする
だからいろいろ解釈は変わる可能性があります
で 私は一応決まっているパーリ文献ではどのように理解しているかっていうね
ところは説明していって
日本語訳の場合は漢文ではどのように理解しているかっていうことを説明してますから
そこら辺でいろんなところでちょっと変わることっていうのは当然ながら出てくる
だからどんな解釈を受け取るかっていうことは
それは自由ですし それより先に
一応こちらのお話も聞いた方がいいんじゃないかなと
だから必ずしも私がやっている解釈は正しいと
それを認めなさいという意味ではありません
絶対聞かんぞという態度は良くないというだけなんです
そういうことで 最初に私は言葉一つ一つ意味を言います
で この二つの偈っていうのは
ある一つの言葉中心に回転しているんですね
サーレという言葉 その言葉を中心にして回っているんです
で サーレというのは何でしょうかね
これはいろんな意味で使えます
しかし サンスクリット語やらパーリ語だったら意味もはっきりしていて
英語ではエッセンスという言葉がありますよ
これカタカナでも使ってるみたいです
普通私たちはエッセンスと発音しますけど
カタカナにするとどんな発音になりますかね
エッセンス  エッセンスという
で これはカタカナ語になってくるとどんな意味かとわからないんだけど
それはいろんなものに当てはめられます
科学とかそういうところではね
化学とかね 薬学とかね
そういうところで使うし
もしかするとその意味の方が優先で理解している可能性もあります
で その中からでも一般的に取れるとは思います
エッセンスというもの
そういう この薬やらね
食べ物やら そういう場合はこの
もうこれが体にいい あれが体にいいという話がありますね
で 例えばこの進めていたけど
ゴマが体に宜しいと 大変健康にいいと
まあ老化現象はもうなくなるんだと
ゴマ食べると それで科学的に研究して
ゴマの中にこのセサミンという何かある成分があるんだと
で これがとてもいいんだと
というと まあ普通の食べ物ではなくて
もう本当に老化現象をなくしてくれる機能っていうのは
ゴマに入っているセサミンという成分なんですね
それでそれがエッセンスになっちゃうんですね
それで体に必要な量を取ろうと思っちゃうと
まあ一日四十グラムか六十グラムとか
まあかなりの量食べなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんですね
これがどう考えても無理
そうするとこのゴマに
ただその必要な成分だけではなくて
また他のものもたくさん入ってるんだから
もしかすると余分なものをたくさん取ったことになりますね
だから結局自分期待する結果が出てこなくなるんです
もう油の量もすごい多いし
他のもののものもたくさんなるし
だから一日必要なセサミン取ろうと思って
まあ毎日四十グラムと五十グラムぐらいもうもう食べていっちゃうと
かえって別な病気になってくる可能性もあります
それでそれは科学的にゴマをいろいろ処理して
セサミンという成分だけを取ると
成分だけ取って それを何か薬なんかの形にして飲んだりすると
まあそうすると一日百グラムぐらいのゴマのエッセンスでも
この一錠で飲み込むことは可能になっちゃうんですね
だからそうやって一番必要な有効な成分をとって
余計なものは捨ててしまうという工程なんですね
例えばCビタミンもたくさん取らなくちゃいけないと
大抵毎日レモンの個ぐらいは食べられませんね
三個のところが一個も食べられません
[笑い]それでまあ いろんなものから
まあこのアスコビックス酸でしたっけ
まあそういうものだけ取ってもらう
それで今売ってるんですね
一錠はもうレモン百個分ありますよとかね
まあ本当かどうかはわかりませんだけどね
まあまあ 取ってみたって別に全然効き目はないんだからね
おそらくまあ商売だろうとは思いますけど
しかし この専門的なところはね
例えば医者が推薦したりする場合はちゃんと効き目はありますよ
その時はまあインチキ薬作って売るわけにはいきませんだから
まあちゃんと機能はしています
私たちは普通の店で買ってますからね
それはもうもしかするともうわからないんですね
もうだから百個分のレモンのビタミンC取っても
それでもビタミンC足らないというね
体に これどういうことか分からないんですけど
そういうことで エッセンスというのはこの有効成分なんですね
それ一つの意味で それで一般的な私たちの日常の感覚的な世界になってくると
やっぱりこの役に立つものということになるんです
だからゴマのセサミンというものは役に立つものなんですよ
レモンのCビタミンは役に立つものなんですね
それがパーリ語になってくるとサーラというんですね
それで役に立つもの 有効成分という言葉で入れ替えてみると
この意味はものすごい簡単にわかると思います
それで一番目の言葉はアサーレ
アサー アっていうのは否定形でサーラはないんだと
いわゆる有効成分がないもの
アサーレというと有効成分がないものについてなんですね
アサーレサーラマティノ
サーラというのはまた有効成分というの
マティノっていうのは思い込んで考えてという意味なんですね
思い込むっていうことじゃないね
そういう思考で 考えで思ってっていうことですよ
そこでアサーレ 有効成分ないものについてサーラマティノ
役に立つものがあると思って
役に立たないものについては役に立つと思う
意味わかりやすいでしょ
役に立たないものなんですが
役に立つだろうという思いを持っている
それでこの二行目 サーレッチャサーラダッシーノなんですけど
それ分析してサーレッチャサーラダッシーノ
サーレ またロカティブケースで書いてますから
サーラっていうのは役に立つ
だから役に立つものについて
チャはただ結ぶためにつなげるために使っている言葉で
直訳はアンドという意味なんですね
サーレッチャサーラダッシーノ
アサーラ役に立たないというダッシーノ意見を持っている
だからマティノダッシーノっていうのは言葉二つですけど
意味は同じなんですね
サーレッチャサーラダッシーノ
このマタ マティ マティでもよろしいし
マタとも言うし それからダッサンという言葉あります
その二つともこの人々の考え方について言ってるんですね
何か考えて 何か結論を出して
私はこういう考え方だよと
こういう意見を持ってますよということことなんですね
そこで二行目はサーレチャ
サーラに役に立つものについてはサーラダッシーの役に立たないという意見を持っている
もう一度繰り返します
役に立たないものについて役に立つだろうという意見があって
役に立つものについては役に立たないだろうという意見を持っている
それで三行目と四行目はもうものすごい簡単に論理的に成り立つんです
そういう条件であるならば
テー 彼らが その人々がサーラン
このエッセンスというものをナアディガッチャンティ
体験はしません 獲得することはできませんという意味なんです
ナは否定形でアディガッチャンティ
アディガッチャンティっていうのはこの
えーと まあどちらにでも使えますが
ものだったら自分でもらう
いただく 獲得するということなんですね
まあ例えばゴマの有効成分を取ろうと思って
ゴマを絞って油取ってからのカスを食べているとかね
もしかするとセサミンという成分がカスにないかもしれません
それは油に溶けるものですから
油と一緒に出て行っちゃうんですね
そうすると いくら油取ったゴマのカスは
それも美味しいことは確かに美味しいんですよ
しかし その人の体にはセサミンという成分が全然入ってこないんです
それは大量にも食べられますよ
また面白いことに 普通のゴマよりも油取ったものはいろいろ
もうクッキーも作られるし
いろんなお菓子も作られるし
普通の料理 いろいろなものにいくらでも作られ
使えます だから結構量食べられます
グラムは困ったなと 軽々とグラムでもグラムでも食べられます
しかし ゴマがグラム食べたと思っても
その人はサーラ エッセンスをとってないんですね
その場合は だからものの場合は取るという習慣も獲得するということになります
お釈迦様はもののことを言っているのではないんですからね
アディガッチャティっていうのはやっぱり経験することなんですね
心で得ることなんです
体でものを得ることではないんですね
まあとにかくパーリ仏典ではアディガッチャティということは
この何か心で得ることを意味するんですよ
それは一般的な日本語では何か得るではなくて
なるということになるんですね
得るといえばものが得得たものはなくなる可能性ありますね
なるということはもうならなくならないんですね
私は何々になりましたという場合はね
それはもうまた自分がなったものだから
もうなくなるということはありえないんですね
ですから アディガッチティっていうのはなるということなんですね
それでて彼らはサーラン
この有効成分というものを役に立つものにはならないんですね
獲得しない 経験しない
ということは結論になります
そこで次の番目で理由を言うんです
もう一度 なぜならばということ
なぜならば それがミッチャーサンカッパゴーチャラ
ミッチャーっていうのは間違っている
やってはいけないということで
間違っていると言えばやってはいけないことだからね
サンカッパというのは思考
ミッチャーっていうのは間違っている
サンカッパは思考 ゴーチャラっていうのは習慣的に我々は常にやっているという意味なんですね
ゴーチャラというのは別な場所で
私は訳するときはなわばりという言葉で訳しますけど
その場所によって言葉は変えますが
いわゆるミッチャーサンカッパ
だからサンカッパは思考
思考のなわばりと言ったってもいいんですよ
この思考が動かしているなわばりが間違っているところで
やってはいけないところなんですね
そうするとわからなくなっちゃいますので
ミッチャー間違っているサンカッパ思考ゴーチャラ習慣になっている
間違っている思考が習慣になっているので
て彼らがサーランナーディガッチャンティエッセンスを役に立つことには至らないと
そのようにこのお釈迦様の
この特に偈で唱えるもの
おっしゃっているものっていうのは
論理的にコンパクトにしているんです
意訳は全くできないようにと
好き勝手な解釈はできない
論理的にはきちんとコンパクトにするんです
で このよっぽどの文学的な天才的な能力ない人でない限りは
天才的な能力能力がない限りは
何か文章を語ったりすると
このコンパクトにぴったしてすわりということは難しいんです
そういう言葉っていうのは世の中ではありますけどね
しかし少ないんですね
このもう知恵の鋭い もうみんなずっと覚えておいて
勉強したり 学んだり 卒中引用したり
何々さんがこういうことを言ったんではないかとかね
そういうふうに引用したりする言葉っていうのは
まあそれほどたくさんあるわけじゃないんですね
だから 一つ一つの文章で何か語っても
コンパクトに論理行程という
この これはちゃんときちんと完璧にしてしゃべらなくちゃいけないんですね
だから この仏典で出てくる偈文
偈というこの詩ですけどね
全部まあ徹底的に努力しているんですね
そういう論理的に完成して言うということ
なんでそこまで言うかというと
すごい単純ですよ 役に立つものについては役に立たないという思考を持っている
役に立つも立たないものについて役に立っているんだという思考を持っている
その間違っている思考を習慣になっているので
そういう人々はエッセンスというかね
役に立つものには至らないんだと
すごい単純ですよ だからやっぱり行でまあ成り立つようになってます
それは仏教のは何ですかね
あれは論理とロジックというかね
まあというものも後から発展したんですけど
そこでどのようにブッダの教えがね
ロジカルプロセスはどのようになっているかという
昔書いたテキストとかね
インドではこのロジックというものは仏教で始めたんです
インドに書かれた最初の論理本といえば
もう仏教のお坊さんが書いたものなんですよ
この皆様ご存知の龍樹という人にしても
純粋論理なんですね 語っているのは
しかし この純粋論理語るということは
仏教は認めて 認めてないんです
純粋に論理だけ いわゆる英語で言うシンボリックロジックというものありますね
それはもう役に立たないし
認めませんけどね はい
まあ こちらは一応思考が間違っていると
これは別な具体的な例に入れ替えてみると
水は火だと思っている
火は水だと思っている
と人が一向に水を得ることもできないし
火を得ることもできなくなっちゃうんですね
なぜならば その人が水が必要な時は火を得るんですよ
間違っているんだから
勘違いしているんだから
火が必要になってくると水を得るんですね
まあそれで一偈の意味はそういうもので
二偈はそちらの反対の意見で
まあそれほど説明することはないんです
サーランチェサーラトーニャットはサーランチェ
サーラであるもの いわゆる役に立つもの
エッセンスがあるもの
サーラトーニャットは
それが役に立つんだよとよく知って
ニャットはというのは知って
サーラはサーラとして見る
知る 役に立つものは役に立つと知る
アサーランチェアサーラと
アサーラは いわゆる役に立たないものは役に立たないんだろうと
と知る それニャットはということは両方に入ります
サーランチェサーラトーニャットはアサーランチェアサーラと
で 彼らはサーランアディガッチャンティ
サーラというもの エッセンスというもの
役に立つものをアディガッチャンティ獲得する
なる そういう役に立つように
理由はサンマーサンカッパゴーチャラ
サンマー正しい サンカッパ思考を慣れ
慣れているんだからね
習慣にしているんだから
正しい思考を習慣にしているんだから
もう 役に立つものは得られるんだよと
だから一と二の間はただ肯定か否定かぐらいだけの差で一つの意味なんですね
全部 で それだけの意味だったら
なんだこんなもう当たり前のことではないか
そんなのは言う必要ないと
と思うんですね みんな
普通に 何も情報を伝えていないんではないかと
大体論理的に完璧に語ると
その勘違いはすごく起こるんです
それは聞く人の頭の悪さなんですよ
で 聞く人々は論理的にできてないんだから
なんだかんだでやっぱりわからない状態で生きているんですよ
それで誰かがすごく厳密にこの完成したことを言うと
それはああ なるほどと一発で何も考えないでわかるんです
何も考えないでわかったことで
別に大したことない 別に何も情報伝えてくれたわけじゃないと
私たちはこの情報だと取っているものは
この論理的にガタガタなものなんです
論理的にガタガタ それから証拠は足らん
そうするとすごい考えが足りますよとかね
みんなに言いふらして
あんたどう思いますか？とかね
いう風なこの混乱状態に陥ることはすごい知識だと思ってるんです
それはもう私 これ大変な説明難しいんですよ
これはもうかなり人間の思考を研究しないと簡単にわかるものじゃない
だから情報を出してくれていても
どんなことでも情報になるんだからね
私にも特別なことだったら
この間こういうことが起きましたと言えますけど
これは朝から晩までのことだから
ちょっと言いにくいんです
で どういうことかというと
やっぱりこの言ってることは本当にその通りかと
はっきりわからない その場合は
それはすごく知識得たと思っちゃう
だからいくら経っても世の中は混乱からは脱しないんです
例として何を言えばいいんでしょうかね
体が不浄なものであるっていう
ことですか  うん？ 体が不浄なものであるっていう風に思うっていうことは
その通りなんだけれども
普通の人は体は不浄なものと思ってない
大切なものだっていうふうに思ってるってこと
私が考えてるのはそういうことよりも
この一般的な知識の世界なんです
知識っていうのはどういうものかと
まあ例えば もうこれはもうあまりいい例じゃないんですけど
例えば地球が丸いということは事実ですけど
これはあんまり驚きも何もしないんですね
そこで富士山のところである人が UFO 発見しましたと
写真撮ったというと これはもう大騒ぎになるんです
黒人人間とか あのニュースも
かなり大騒ぎになるんです
それでアンタ知ってますか？とかね
写真見たんですか？とかね
で 曖昧でガタガタで証拠足らないんですよ
もう一つ 例えばイラクは大量破壊兵器作ってるかないかと
これ結構国際ニュースではいつでも外国のニュース聞くともうもう十五分ごとにそればっかり言ってるんですね
同じことを繰り返して繰り返して
一回だけで十分でしょうに
はっきりしないんだよというぐらいのことで
だから例えばアメリカはもう大量破壊兵器は確実に作っているんだと決めているんですね
ですから どんなレポートが出てもそれは違うと
私たちが出してる結論を正しいというふうにレポートを持ってこいという
すごい凶暴に今頑張ってるんですね
だから 国連から行く査察団は誰の説教も聞いてはいけないんだけど
やっぱりアメリカの言葉を聞いて
その通りに研究調べなくちゃいけないんですね
だから それがすごい大ニュースで
もう一生懸命そちらはそちらで
イラクはイラクで それでやっと査察団はもう決まってる工程に入ったんです
いわゆる決まってることっていうのは
行く前にもイラクはもうちゃんと情報を言ってくれない
もう査察させてくれない
かなり邪魔しているんだと
だから引き上げますという結果決まってるんです
行く前から 最初はそういかなかったんですよ
イラクは何だかんだでも見せたり教えたりしたんですね
これでダメだと この方法ではと
そうすると関係ない余計なものを調べたりする
それでイラクがどうしても余計なもの
関係ないものを調べたりすると
何やってるんですかと
あんた方は大量破壊兵器をやってるかないか調べに来たんではないか
だからそこら辺調べなさいという態度をとっているんです
そこは全く興味ない 今は
別なものを調べている
そうするとイラクはただのスパイではないかと
言うと もうそれでうまいことやっぱり協力してくれない
こちらが頼むデータは出してくれないということはもう成り立つ
だからそういうからくりは一応今は起きてますけど
で とにかくすごいニュースで大騒ぎになっていてとかね
とにかく世の中で このどこかで幽霊が出た
お化けが出たって 大体ワイワイになるニュースみたいなものを見ると
やっぱり証拠はない はっきりしない
どこかおかしい どこか変
そういうものがニュースであって
情報であって知識なんですよ
決して嘘を言って人を騙すないということは情報でもないし
ニュースでもないし 面白くもないし
聞く耳も持たないし それ誰かが嘘っていうのはとんでもないことだと
事実に基づいて語るべきだと言ったら
何をね 当たり前のこと面白くないよと言うんです
だからそこは普通の世の中の人間の思考パターン
そういうふうにできているんです
そういう思考パターンでいる限りは
知識得られない 得られないんですよ
ずっと混乱のまんまで
で終わっちゃうんです
だからブッダの言葉になってくると
これは論理的にはもうほとんどの
たまにこのなかなかこのアイデアが複雑で
論理的な完成できないところもないわけないんだけど
その場合は文章長くなるんですよ
たった一つの項目を言うために
経典一つぐらいしゃべることになってしまうんですね
そういう時もありますけど
この法句経っていうのはいろいろポイントを短く単純に言ってるところを集めたところですからね
それだけじゃなくて またありますけどね
たくさん だからダンマパダというテキストの特色は
この偈一個一個独立させることはできます
ですから 軽く引用できますというぐらいのことで
もっとすごいところを教えてやりますよ
それは一個一個取り出すことできる場合もできない場合もあります
うん だから私が言いたいのは別なポイントで
このもうこれは当たり前ではないかとね
やっぱり役に立つものを役に立たないと勘違いすると
役に立つものは得られないんだよということも当たり前ということになるんですね
でも当たり前では済まないんですよ
お釈迦様は人生論について語ってますから
では私たちはそういうふうな生き方をしているかということに持っていかなくちゃいけない
私たちは何か思考したり判断したりすると
正しく思考したり判断したりしますかと
その場合はそちらの例になってくるんです
我々は本当に役に立つもの
こんないい加減な勘違いするわけないではないかという態度をとって取れるかと
こんなことを言ったって
もうアホじゃないかと思うでしょ
役に立つもの役に立たないんだと
水が火だと 火は水だと思っちゃ
あんたおかしいアホやではないかと
そんなことを私たちはやるわけじゃないという気持ちになるんですよ
そんなこと誰がやるもんかと
当たり前のことではないかという態度に心が変わる
それでまた考えてほしいのは
では私という人がいつでも役に立つものと役に立たないものをはっきり区別分別していますかと
もし分別しているならば
私という人の生き方が完璧な成功しているはずなんでしょう
何も悩むことはない 落ち込むこともない
もう幸福三昧で生きていられるはずなんです
期待外れでしたとかね
希望叶わなかったとかということは成り立たないはずなんです
だってしっかりと区別判断できる
役に立つもの 自分にとっては
役に立たないもの それも自分にとってはと
する人はっきり区別してくれる人は
わざと役に立たないと知った上でそれをやろうとはしないでしょうに
例えば道路を渡ろうとすると
わざと車が来る時まで待ってきて飛び込むということをしないでしょうに
なぜならば それは役に立たない行為だと分かっているんだから
だから役に立たない行為だと分かると
それはしないということはもう決まってるんです
それで私たちはこの踏切が落ちて
電車が来る時に時を見計らって線路を渡ろうとは絶対しませんし
車が来る時見て道路を渡ろうとはしないし
その時点ではこれが役に立たないと知っている
役に立たないと知っているものはやめるというのはもうもう決まっているパターンです
それは常識的なパターンです
では私たちはそんなもんですかと
人生は 役に立たないことは全然やらない人々ですかと
いわゆるブッダの言葉から言えば
人間の生き方は幸福ですか
不幸ですかと 人生は苦ですか
楽ですかと それで人生は生きることは苦であると
ドゥッカであると お釈迦様が研究して結論出している
それはそうでないとは誰にも言えない
言う人はいますけど 本当は言えない
常識な人間だったら 言う人はただもういい加減なことを言ってるだけで
いい加減な加減なことだったらいくらでも言えますからね
聖書というものはもう何万冊でも書けますよ
いい加減なことを書けるんだと
書くんだったらね 論理は要りません
証拠は要りません ただ書くと
それだったらいくらでも書けます
それでいい加減な思考を持ってる人々は
やっぱり生きることはこの上ない幸福だよと言っているはず
言ってるかもしれませんだけど
実際はそれはそう言えるものじゃない
生きることは苦しみになるんですね
たとえアメリカの大統領になろうとも
生きることは楽じゃないんですね
かなりきつい いつでもあらゆる不満で
あらゆる不安で悩まなくちゃいけない
この不安不満というのは
人それぞれ様々ですが
結果は同じ 会社があまり儲かってない場合は
もうそれほど能力ないサラリーマンの方々は
随分自分がこれから食べていられるかないかというね
リストラになるんではないかというすごい悩み
不安 恐怖感はある それで
アメリカのブッシュ大統領が別に食べていられないかなどうか
そんな悩みは全くないんだから
元々すごい金持ちでしょうし
これからもう退職してからはね
一生政府のお金で贅沢して食っていられますからね
ろくな仕事もしていないのに
もうかなり給料もらうんですよ
もう仕事終わったら だから仕事収入から見れば世界で最高な仕事なんですね
ただ もうパフォーマンスは年間年間やる
誰が書いてくれる文章は読み上げる
ちゃんとしたアクセントで
インテリが使う英語のアクセント
どうせインテリたちでもインテリといってもそういう人々だからね
英語 それも苦労する必要はない
発声 発音の訓練する必要はない
普通習ってるんだからね
それパフォーマンス それからもう仕事終わっても
もうお金に困ることはない
で では不安ないんですかと
不満がないんですかと
確実にある だから悩みは人それぞれ
人それぞれなんですけど
精神的にはみんな不安と不満で生きていなくちゃいけないということは
人生はドゥッカである
苦しみであるということは
決して否定できない事実になっているんです
では これは成功している生き方か
失敗している生き方かと決めてみると
成功とは言えないんですね
ずっと努力するのは不満をなくすためなんですよ
[音楽]不安は嫌なんですよ
安定した精神で生きていきたいんですよ
それに頑張ってるんですよ
人は結婚するのももういくらか安定しようと思って
子供を作るのも いくらか安定して
不安がなく 楽しく生きてみようではないかと
そういうすべての努力は
不安 不満 不安定状態をなくそうという努力でしょう
では 成功しているんですかと
だから金は儲けたかもしれませんよ
人間それが成功と言うんだけど
仏教はそれじゃない あなたは精神的な不安をなくしたんですか？不満をなくしたんですかと
それを聞いているんです
ある人は 私はお金よりは知識が欲しいやと思って
とことん研究したりして
すごい知識人になるかもしれません
それが世界は成功しましたという
でも仏教はそれではないんで
聞いているのは それで知識人になったあなたは精神的な不安をなくしたんですかと
悩み苦しみなくしたんですかと
というと 答えはみんな同じ答え出すんですよ
だから 俗世間の成功という言葉と
仏教で我々が言う成功という言葉のスタンスは違うんです
俗世間でいうのは もうそれなりにちょっとお金が入ったら成功するということだけのことだからね
俗世間の成功というのは九十九パーセント収入に関わるものでしょ
ほんのちょっとですね
別なことでも頑張ってみて成功しましたよというのに
そういうことで で 話に戻りますけど
いろいろことにチャレンジはするんだけど
このチャレンジしたものが成功することっていうのはそっちはあるし
しかし精神ってこのチャレンジなぜ始めたかというと
もともと不安 不安定あったんだからなんです
で 何かにチャレンジする
チャレンジしたものが成功しますが
もともとからあった精神的な不安
苦しみが消えたんですかというと
それはそのまんまか もっと増えたかなんでしょうね
大体はもっと増えたっていうことなんです
社会的に我々はいろんなものにチャレンジして
上へ行けば行くほど 不安というのはどんどん増えていくんです
それでその次に当てはめてみますよということは
あんたは失敗しているんだと
あんたはやってはいけないことをやっているんだと
精神的な不安 不満をなくそうと思って
精神的な不安 不満を増やしたんではないかと
ということは サーレチャアサーラダシヌなんですよ
役に立つものだと役に役に立たないと思ったんではないかと
役に立たないものに役に立つものだと勘違いしたんではないんですかと
だからあなたは不安なくそうと思って
結局は不安をさらに増やしたんではないかと
安全に道路を渡りたいと思って
見計らって車が通る時渡ったんではないかと
だから安全ではなかったと
ということで これはみんなやっていることになるんです
だから これをもう簡単に聞こえただけで言っている意味が簡単単純ではなくて
すごい人生論なんですよ
だから これ解釈するためにブッダの哲学を裏にないと解釈できない
ただ 自由に誰が解したっても
それはもうブッダが教えたことじゃないんです
お釈迦様にはお釈迦様なりに人生論という哲学というものありましたから
それに基づいてそういうものはちょっとちょっとちらちらと一つ歌一つとかね
詩一つとか言う で 誤解しないでください
ブッダたるものが詩なんか言うはずがないんでしょ？とかね
そういや それはすごいインテリの人でしたし
こういうのは日常茶飯事のことで
学問も満たしてましたし
だから即興ですぐ歌で言えるんですよ
詩で それはごく普通な能力で
それからインド文化では
もう私たちもよくやりますよ
自分の国の言葉ででも
一生懸命苦労してなんとか歌の紙は縦長い紙に書くということはないんですけど
その場で即興でちゃんと節を合わせて言うんですよ
それは仕事にしている人々もいます
突然どこかに呼ばれて
呼ばれたらもう何でも歌で言う
だから前もって歌を作って暗記して行っちゃうと全く無意味で
誰も認めません その場であった出来事についてさっさと言わなくちゃいけない
それまたただ言葉を並べただけでダメなんで
何かすごい昨日聞いた言葉ないと
だからみんなすごく楽しくて
もう笑っちゃうというふうなものでないと
だから歌を作るということは
まあごく普通なことで
ですから お釈迦様もまあ卒中まあいったんでしょうとは思いますけどね
それは芸術的な文学的な遊びではないんです
やっぱり歌で言った方がすぐ覚えやすいし
締まっているしね アイデアが
それから余計な言葉がないし
それでこの芸を独立して自分なりに解釈したっても
お釈迦様おっしゃる人生論というのは出てこないんです
お釈迦様の人生論というのは万人に当てはめるように言うんですよ
ある特定の人間にだけ当てはめて
他の人には関係ないということになりません
聖書を読んでみたんですけどね
最近まだたまたま読み直してるんです
で 子供頃で読んだんだからね
もっと大人になってから読み直さないと
やっぱり普遍的じゃないと一言葉も
普遍的に人類について語ったものは何かあるかというふうに
その角度で見るとないんですね
ずーっとこの聖書の中で
この愛という言葉についてのところを全部調べてみたんです
それは人類に対する愛じゃないんです
ある特定の人間に限って語っているんですね
これが全然誰も言わないことというのは
まあ宗教は批判してはいけないという道徳的というかね
そういうマナーかどうか分かりませんだけどね
何かすごく嫌になってくるんですね
そうなっちゃうと やっぱり普遍的に人類に向かって語らない
ある特定の人間に語る
コーランも読んでみようかなと思ったんあれほど読みにくいというか
もう中途半端なっていうのはね
ものっていうのは すごいもう嫌になるんで
やっぱりあれは読む本じゃなくて
みんなこの ただ単に唱えるぐらいのもんだからね
しょうがないんですけどね
読んで意見取ろうと思うと結構難しくなるんです
とにかくそちらもそういう特定なんですね
普遍的で 例えばまあ例えば科学研究なんかしたりしてね
で いろんなものを発見しちゃうと
人間に関係あるもの それは誰にでも関係あると
だから 例えばあるウイルスにある特定の人間がかからないんだよとわかると
科学者はそれで黙ってはいません
その国民は神様に恵み
なんとかご褒美もらっている
だからこのウイルスにかからないんだよとは
そうは黙っていません
徹底的にその人々の体を調べるんですよ
調べて原因を発見して
なぜ調べるかというと
それが他の人々にも役に立つようにできないかと
そうすると その結果がすべての人間に当てはめるものになります
で ブッダの教えの特色はそちらにあります
すべて一切の生命に当てはまる
人間だけではないんです
どうせブッダは人間で
我々人間で 私たちに語っているのは
まあそれはまあ実践面では当たり前ですけど
犬は説法を聞くのは聞いたことはないんですけど
で もうついたって分からないし
だからそんな話は関係ないんですけど
しかし ポイントはすべての生命に当てはまるものなんですよ
そっちが起こるんだったら
犬さえも不幸になるんだからね
それははっきりしています
あまりにも欲張ると犬も不幸になります
優しさあると犬でも猫でも他の動物でも
もうかなり幸せになって人気者になります
だからメス犬は 例えば猫の母ちゃんにもおっぱいあげちゃうと
これテレビでも出ますからね
それ何のこともない そういう優しさっていうのは
もうそういうたまたまそういうこともあるでしょうに
自分が子供におっぱいあげてるんだけど
また他の動物の子供いて
そちらこちらがおっぱいあげたり
何のことなく同窓という感じで
それでおっぱい飲んでるんだから
母親らしくちゃんと舐めてあげたり
いろいろ面倒まで見ると
だからそういう風に心が広くなると
動物でも結構人気者になって
みんなに愛されるようになって
なんか立派なものとして扱われますよ
だからブッダの真理はみんなに当てはめるものなんです
これ当てはめないところは実践のところですよ
だから実行できるかないかということはね
そういうことで この芸はすべての生命に当てはめるんですよ
すべての生命がもうあべこべで意味あるものは意味がないと勘違いする
意味があるもの意味がないものには意味があると勘違いする
そんな勘違いで生きていると
一向に意味あるものにはたどり着かない
だから一向に不安 苦しみからは脱出できないんだよと
ということを言っています
では この意味あるものと意味がないものって何でしょうかね
こちらではこの見方ですね
言ってるのは やっぱり意味あるもの意味ないものははっきりしています
意味ないものっていうのは苦しみを増えるものなんですよ
意味があるものってのは苦しみは減るもんですよ
だから我々は判断して生きています
この判断して生きている場合は
自分の判断は苦しみを減る方向へ判断しなくちゃいけない
苦しみが増える方向で判断してはいけないんですね
それでその判断はどんなものかと
ではどのように判断すればよろしいかと
別な経典などなどではいっぱい語ってます
いっぱい語ってますけど
そこら辺言うとみんなどうかなと
前にこちらの方おっしゃった通り
例えばこの体は本当は不浄なんですが
これ言うとみんな嫌な気持ちになるんです
で それはブッダの話で
体は不浄なものであると
それでこちらで経典として挙げている経典が 1つありましてね
こんな汚い体を持ってよくも人を馬鹿にしたりするんでしょうと
アホでアホしか言うこともないんだ
そんな人にと そういうことをなんかすごいみんな攻撃的で刺激的ではないか思うかもしれない
それじゃないんですよ
それで自分をすごい立派な人間な人を馬鹿にするんじゃないんだと
他人を高慢に見るんじゃないんだと
自分の体って何なのかと
こんなあっちこっちから不浄な悪臭を汚いものばっかり垂らしっぱなしで
目から耳から鼻から口から体からいろんな穴からもう汚いものばっかり垂らしながら
自分が偉いとよく思うことだと
そういうふうなことで心がすごい謙虚になって
高慢がなくなって 体に対する愛着が消えてしまう
それが意味ある世界なんですけど
それは誰ももう聞きたくもないんですね
あなたは美しい方ですねと言っちゃうと
すぐもう飛び上がって舞い上がって喜んじゃうんですね
だからあなたすごく美しい方ですねと言ったところで
なんで飛び上がって喜ぶんですかね
あまりにも勘違いですよ
そういう勘違いで生きていると確実に不幸になるという
今も不幸で これからも不幸が増えるんであって
減ることはないということになるんです
そこでお釈迦様おっしゃっている無常ということはね
みんなのこのことをわかっているんだと言うんですけどね
私 この間も誰かが言ったんですけど
それはまあまあよくわかっているんだよと
そしたらね じゃああんた悟っているんですかと
だから次は言わなかった
いい加減なことを言うなよということも言いたかった
それは言わなかったんですよ
私はね たとえ仏教を研究しても
あ なるほど すごい単純明快な理屈で難しくない
わかるんだよ それが勘違いですよ
このゲーム 私はだから最初にすごい単純な意味を教えてあげたんです
えらい分かりやすいんですよと
でもやっ 立ちませんね
それだったら 何も情報伝えてないことになるんです
裏はすごいんですよ 革命的なことを教えているんです
明らかに人類もどんな生命も考えたこともない
考えることも不可能と言えるほどの革命的なことを言っているんです
分かったらすぐ幸福になるし
心が一切の汚れから落ち落ちてしまって
脱出して解脱体験できるんです
それでこの意味のあるもの意味のないものの区別にまた戻ります
意味のないものっていうのは
わかりやすく言えば苦しみが増え増えるもの
それはいろいろありますよ
この経典はおっしゃった出来事は宗教的な哲学の問題なんですけど
それだけも考えてもよろしいんですよ
我々は あの人の意見も素晴らしい
この人の意見も素晴らしい
あの先生の教えも素晴らしい
この先生の教えも素晴らしい
いろんないろんなことを勉強したりするでしょうに
それで心がどうなるんですかね
結局どんどん知らないことばっかし増えるでしょ
あれ何なんでしょうかね
いろんなことを勉強すればするほど
知ってること増えるんじゃなくて
知らないことばっかし増える
わけもわからなくなっちゃう
試しに仏教を勉強するんだったら
真言密教とティベット密教と初期仏教を勉強してみてください
どうなるかと できればちゃんと合わせてみなさいと
頭くるだけやと思いますけどね
だから学者やってるのはこの一部一行合わせる
それは合わせますよ ジグソーパズルでも一部だけだったらはめますけど
でも全部はめなきゃダメですからね
パズルの凸凹たくさんありますからね
4つか 4つか 5つぐらいありますからね
1個だけはめますよ と言ったって
ピッタシはめたということになりません
みんなやってるのはジグソーパズルの 1個1個だけ合わせてみる
だから何勉強したってもなかなかまとめませんね
で まとめて見せるとすっごく嫌になるんですね
私はよくやりますから
どうせ人の嫌味を買うのはなんか趣味みたいになっちゃって
何か言うとすぐまとめて見せる
これはこういうことではないか
えらく嫌になるんです
本人が苦しんで悩んでいるのに
答えをもらったらそれで喜ぶべきなんですけど
喜ばないんですよ だからブッダを理解すると
もうどんな意見でもきちんと把握してまとめるということができますけどね
で それで世の中でそうやっていろいろ教えがある
それ勉強すると私たちは本当に落ち着くかと
あるいはわからないことたくさん増えるかと
例えばキリスト教を勉強してイスラム教を勉強すると
ものすごく困ると思いますよ
どんな神様にするかと
だって性格は全く違うんですよ
でも大元は同じなんですよ
イスラム教も全部この旧約聖書からキリスト新約聖書まで全部そこ繋ぐ流れがあって
そこからムハンマドの話なんですよ
歴史的にはね だからイスラム教で言ってる物語
エピソード 全部旧約聖書にあるものなんです
だったら仲良くやればいいでしょ
その二人が ユダヤ教もそうでしょうし
ユダヤ教 旧約聖書まで
キリスト教は新約聖書
それからコーランでしょうに
それでみんな私はここからここまで
じゃああんた方はここからここはあんた方は仲良くやりましょうということで
いとも簡単にできるはずなんですよ
この 3つの宗教の人々にすっごく仲良くすることは
でも真面目に勉強するとできなくなっちゃうんですね
それが何でしょうかと
旧約聖書は真面目に読むと新約聖書は成り立たなくなっちゃうんです
反対のことを言ってる
だから新約というんだから
この反対のことをハイライトされますよ
だから仲良くできなくなっちゃうんです
イスラム教も今まで旧約新約両方を使って
それの延長線で新しいものを言ったんだけど
それで違うところを行っている
そこをハイライトしてイスラム教にしているんですね
それで元の者とはもう仲が悪くなってしまうんですね
それで新約聖書に現れる神とコーランで現れた神っていうのは全く別人なんですね
それで旧約聖書にで現れた神はまた別人なんですね
この宗教は捨ててしまって
学問的に調べると もう別の人格なんですね
性格も違うし 言ってることも違うし
それで 3つ勉強した人は結構困るでしょうと
どちらの神にしようかと
だから宗教の教えであろうとも
ブッダが言うのは そういう混乱を招くならば
平和を壊すならば 社会の秩序は壊すならば
道徳を犯すならば もう人間の苦しみ増えるだけでしょうと
余計な悩みが付け加えるだけではないかと
それでこのサーラっていうのは
ただあれもいい これもいいではないんですよ
これが勉強したら自分が幸福になるんでしょうかと
精神的な不安が消えるんでしょうかと
世界は平和になるんでしょうかと
生命は互いに慈しみで心配して
愛して生きられるようになるんでしょうかと
慈しみを語りながらやらなかったら
私の怒りがお前の前に落ちるぞと言っちゃうと
これが慈しみじゃないんですよ
で ロッド WRAT これは堂々と聖書にありますから
新約聖書にロッドっていうのは激しい怒りなんですよ
それは神の怒りなんです
ちょっとしたことで怒る人は徹底的にこちらで愛をしなくちゃいけない
なんかトラスカっているかに感じになっちゃうんですね
だからそういうことを勉強して生きてみると
本当にもう何も差別なく
壁なく他人を愛せますかと
いろいろもうそうやっていろいろ問題が出てくる
だからこのあれやこれやとか
知識欲で勉強しても このサーラとアサーラのポイントを気をつけて
勉強してはいけないということじゃないんです
私も勉強しますから この 3つも一応それなりに斜めになめてみたんだからね
でもポイントから脱出しない
ですから 私は混乱したことはないんですね
読んでも これはもうやばいと
神を信仰しなかったら地獄に落ちるんだよと
神の怒りが落ちるんだ
全然それ気にならなかったんですね
なぜならば もうポイントはっきりしていますね
サーラとアサーラはちゃんと区別するんだと
役に立つものは得て 役に立たないものは捨てると
そういうことになってくると
精神的には落ち着いていられます
何を勉強しても これで役に立つ
役に立たないところを我が儘で決めてはいけません
なぜならば 今もみんな失敗しているんだから
すべての人間が役に立つと思って役に立たないことをやっているんだから
だから自分で勝手に決めるんじゃなくて
やっぱり心の不安 心の悩み
精神的な苦しみ 怒り 憎しみ
そういうものが消すことが目的にしておかないと
世界の平和がないのは怒り
憎しみからでしょうに
我が儘 高慢だからでしょうに
だからそれがなくすようにと思考自体変えなくちゃいけない
だから私はもう片っ端から何でも批判しますけど
それは思考を変えることを意味しています
自分が思考を変えているんだから
仏教徒だから 人が言って言っただけで
ああそう いいですよ言わない
役に立つか立たないかと
役に立つということも
この今お釈迦様がおっしゃっている定義で決めるんです
そうするとそれも一つの偏見ではないかとまあ言えるんですが
偏見ではないかと言えるんですが
これは万人に普遍的なことですからね
平和が嫌ということは言えないでしょうね
心の安らぎがよくないと言えないでしょうに
ブッダが特定の人間に語ったわけじゃないんだから
それは誰にでも必要なものだから
まあ偏見という言葉は通じない
それで無常ということをまた言いますけど
無常ということにしたっても
やっぱり無常ということは分かった方が楽しいですよと
理解した方が楽ですよと
そんなにしがみついて
あれやこれや戦うことは消えますよと
心はすっごく穏やかになりますよと
無常ではないんだから
無常とは思わないんだから
我々もいつでも精神的にずっと苦しんでるんですよ
この苦しむ対象はもうとっくに消えているんですよ
自分も消えているんですよ
でもある時は何か起きて
自分がすごく苦しかった
悩むんだ それはその瞬間のことで
次の瞬間の別な心でしょうに
別な条件でしょうに だから持ち運ぶ必要ない
過去を しかし 我々は無常じゃないと勘違いしているんだから
もう悩みが生まれても
それは一生持ち運ぶ 持ち運ぶと
どんどんそれ見事に増えるんですね
実際の悩みよりは 考える時の悩みの方が強烈なんですよ
そういうふうに これは無常に逆らっているんだから生まれること
ですから 真理は無常であると
無常であるということは真理ですよと
すべては無常である で
それを理解することで
その理解に基づいて生きることはサーラなんですね
それで怒り 憎しみも無くすために
お釈迦様は体は不浄であると全て捨てていかなくちゃいけないんだよと
期待っていうのはもう叶わないもんやと言って証拠を出すんですよ
なぜならば みんなそんなことないんだよと偉そうに思っちゃいますからね
そんなことないんだと思ったって
もう期待成功しているのは誰ですかね
その具体的なデータを出そうと思ったら
もう怒って帰るんですよ
証拠を出さないで堂々と言う
それはちょっと仏教徒とは対話できないね
その場合は 努力すれば
もうこれはもうそれぐらい叶いますよと平気で言う
では言ってみなさいと
証拠は それでくだらないことを言うんですよ
あの人は東大に入りたがって
もうもう沼底遊ぶガリベンチもあって入ったんではないかと
それぐらいのことで期待かなったと言えますかと私が聞きたいんですね
あの人は金持ちになりたくてすごい頑張って
もう金持ちになりましたと
だから希望っていうのは叶うもんだよと
そんなのはくだらない
本当は人はそれは期待してないんですよ
東大に入ろうと頑張っても
入らなくても死にませんだからね
生きていられるんだから
入らなかった人はこれは悔しいかもしれませんだけど
それからこれからどうしますかと別な道を選ぶんですよ
どうったこともない 金儲かろうと頑張ったところで
なかなか儲からない うまくいかない
その人はじゃあうまくいかないんだから
それはやめますと 別なところで
どこかで仕事をして給料で生活しますよということになるんです
だから それはそんな大したことはない
それぐらいのことをお釈迦様は知らないわけでもない
だからこの軽々く反対するのは良くないんですよ
それぐらいのこと知らないわけないでしょう
それで在家の方々に向かって教える時は
お釈迦様が言うのは朝早く起きなさいよと
怠けるなよと 汗たらして頑張りなさいと
金無駄遣いするなよと
で あんたの人生成功するんだよとちゃんと言ってますからね
それぐらいのことっていうのはごく普通なことで
それでお釈迦様はそこを明確にするんで
期待は外れますよと どんな人間の期待は死にたくないという
生まれた瞬間からその期待で頑張ってるんです
死なないために でもこれは叶わないんだと
年は取りたくないと 叶いませんよと
そんなことは 病気にはなりたくないと
叶いませんと 衰えたくないと
ずっと必死ですよ だから本当に我々は悩んでるのはそこら辺なんです
それで別なところに入れてるんですよ
だからサーラは取ってないんです
アッサーラ取ってるんです
誰も思ってもないでしょ
私は死にたくない 死にたくないと期待してるわけじゃないんだよ
それはもういつか死ぬんでしょうとかね
平気で言ってしまって
別な期待作って金儲かりたい
人気者になりたいとかね
これでなったんではないか
私は人気者に って では
あなたの悩み苦しみ消えたんですかとこちら聞きたいんですけど
人気になったんだけど
結局悩み苦しみは増えただけで
だから期待叶ってないんですよ
だから そこら辺でわかりやすくする場合は
老いたくないとかね 病気になりたくない
死にたくないとか これはどう踏ん張っても得られないものを
なぜならば全て無常だから
それを理解しなさいよと
事実として徹底的に それと同一してみない
同一しない限りはできないんです
その真理と それやってみなさい
どうなるかとあなたはと
すべての苦しみが消えますよと
無常と同一したところで
同一同じくなるもの 一つになる
これ無理わけじゃないし
なぜならば全て無常だから
自分も無常だから ただ頭勘違いで無常じゃないと思ってるだけのことですよ
この勘違い変えるだけのこと
だから決してできないわけじゃないんです
こういうふうなことで頑張ってみると幸福になるんだよと
サーラは得られますよ
だからこの芸二つで言ってることは
サーラ役に立つものを獲得すること
自分はそういうふうになること
いわゆる幸福になることを言ってるんで
それに必要なのはミッチャーサンカッパというものを捨てて
いわゆる間違ってる思考をやめてサンマーサンカッパ正しい思考を作ることなんです
思考を直せば 全て解決するということなんです
簡単に聞こえますけど
かなりの仕事なんです
なぜならば 人類の中で一人もこの思考で生きてるわけじゃないんです
誰でも無常をわかっているわけじゃない
無常に逆らっている 幸福って何なのかわかってない
お金さえあればいい 大丈夫やというふうに
ずいぶん簡単単純に思っている
不幸って何なのかわかってないんですよ
とにかくこの精神的な悩み
不安 苦しみということはもう棚上げにしているんですね
自分の心なのに それが棚上げにして別なところで探してるんです
幸せを だから自分の悩みをちゃんと見て
それは何なのかと なぜ悩んでいるかというと
自分の心の中で原因が見つかるんですね
自分のわがまま 自分の主観
自分の怒り 自分の憎しみ
誰かにいじめられたと思って
この人は一生怒り 憎しみで生きてると
そのいじめた人は悪いんですかね
いじめた人はいじめたにしたっても
あるいは残酷にいじめたとしたっても
これは短い時間だけでしょうに
人を年間年間時間もう残酷にいじめるということは成り立ちませんだから
それでその恨みを一生持ち運んで苦しむのは誰ですかと
だから あの人のせいで私は不幸だ
苦しんでるんだっていうのはあまりにも勘違いで
私がその人に対して恨みを持ってるんだから私が苦しんでるんだよということが正しい事実なんですよ
自分を残酷にいじめたとしたっても
自分がその人に対して恨みを持つ
これで一生苦しむ 人が与えた害っていうのはほんのわずかなもので
それも時間的な問題だからすぐ消えるもんで
しかし 人に害を与えたところで
精神的な受けるインパクトっていうのはもう生半可なものじゃないでしょ
治らなくなっちゃうんですよ
あれはなんとか専門言葉になりますね
専門的な トラウマもう 하나 PT
それがなかなか大変なもんですよ
人が自分の家に突然入ってきて
何か財布はお金持って逃げて逃げたかもしれません
これでPTSDなんかになってしまうと
盗まれたのはほんのちょっとのお金でしょう
それが別にもうもう 1ヶ月でまた元に戻れるし
どうったことないんですけど
そこから心に映る不安
悩み 憎しみ 怒りっていうのは
人はもう延々と限りなく悩ませる
仏教的に言えば 例えば人に残酷にいじめられたと
1時間いじめられたと
それでその人はもう恨みを持つことになって
一生苦しんでいる それから 70年間生きて生きたとします
この人は 70 年間もあの 1時間の苦しみで悩んできている
肉体的にはどうったことないんです
精神的な それで PTSD なんとかってなんだかんだから言ってることになってしまうと
体も壊れてしまうし それででは仏教的に聞きます
恨みに恨んで憎しみに憎しんでいる人が死んじゃったらどこへ行くんでしょうかね
だからどうなるんです
だからもう例えば それじゃあまあ仮に地獄に落ちるでしょうし
天国に行くわけないんだからね
恨みに恨んでいる人は
憎しみに憎しんでいる人は
それで地獄に落ちたところで
その人にもし超能力あったら
自分をいじめた人はどこに行くか
もしかして天国に行くかもしれません
いるかもしれません さらに恨むんですよ
なんだこれと でも 合論はそんなもんですよ
それで私は人間で ブッダの話も聞いたら全く嘘ではないかとあれはと
もう勘違いするかもしれない
嘘じゃないんです 私は何々さんにいじめられて
それで一生苦しんで でもいじめた人は天国にいて
いじめられた被害者たる私はなんで
そこでさらに恨むことになって
地獄の中でまた独房に入れると
ということになるんですよ
そういうのはあの合論であって事実なんです
事実とか天国地獄ではなくて
この問題は自分の心にあるんだよと
だからブッダはどうだって
いかなる場合でも他を憎んではいけないと無条件で言うんですよ
他宗教では条件付きで言うんですね
言うならば それは慈しみではありませんと
いかなる場合でも他を憎んではならぬ
それは正しいんだと これはサン
サンカッパだよと 正しい思考だよと
正しい思考というのは
あなたは幸福になる思考だと
あんた不幸になりたくないでしょうに
だったら幸福になる思考を持ちなさいよと
言い訳言うなよと それで比丘たちに言うのは
もう乱暴な人々は鋸で自分の体を手足を切断しても怒ってはあかんと
嫌な気持ち作ってはいけませんと
もし乱暴な人が自分は両足を取って鋸で横に 2つに切る
その時ももう嫌な気持ち作っちゃうと
あなたは私の教えを実践していないんだよと
ネメーサーサナカロホーティ
彼が私のサーサナ 教えをやってないんだと
それぐらい厳密に言ってるんで
それ以上は語れませんよ
人間には 恐ろしい人が来て
人々が来て 何もやったことない
やってない自分を捕まって
それで両足で取って鋸で 2つに切る
その時でも その人々は幸福でありますようにと思わなくちゃいけない
心は慈しみで溢れるようにしなくちゃいけないんだと
それは負け犬の教えではない
ではない それは幸福の教えです
その人は幸福になる その人にとっては願ってもないチャンスだから
慈しみを実践するために
この時ですよ とやるべきなのは
やってみると その人は見事な結果を得られるんです
そのようにこの不安あって
悩みがあって それを心にあって
それがなくすことは幸福なんですよ
それが分かっていない
幸福はどこかで探す 本当の自分の不幸の原因を棚上げにしている
だから正しいものを正しくないと勘違いしている
誰でもやっていることで
それで心の中に原因がある
憎しみ怒りが自分の心の中にある
だから人のせいで不幸になるとは思わないんですね
人のことで大変なことには卒中になりますけどね
そんなのはその時その時だけのことで
でも心は汚してはならないんだと
汚れた心で死んじゃうと
必ずしも不幸になるんだよと
さらに不幸になるんだよと
というのは一般的な教えで
そこら辺で話を終了したいと思いますけど
こちらのポイントはサーラという言葉
役に立つって何なのか
役に立つっていうことは幸福になる道
幸福というのは心の不安
悩みを 悩みをなくすこと
精神的な心の問題です
客観的な外の世界のことではありません
豪邸を造ったかないか
プレハブなんとかというところに住んでいるかないか
それではありません 木の下に住んでいるかないかと
仏弟子たちは木の下に住んでいたんだから
でも幸福でしたけど お釈迦様も年取ってくると
どこかどこかで泊まったりしたんですけど
それでももう住所はなかったんだからね
あっちこっちあっちこっち行ったりする
住むところがなかったんです
どこかへ行ったら そこら辺どこかに建物で
みんな一般的にそこは建物っていうのはあったんだからね
公の場っていうのはそこでね
その夜はいる 公の場でもずっと 1年居ちゃうと困りますからね
村人たちは そこでまあ時期終わったらそこ帰る
帰る時はまた来るんだからって自分の荷物置いていくことはしません
それで不幸でしたね 逆でしょう
最高な幸福 だからそれは体をもって教えていたんですよ
住所がないのに最高の幸せだと
ある日 真冬 もう家もなくて
外でお釈迦様いたんですよ
夜 ホッカイロというんですか？カイロ
あれもないでしょうね
そこでこの有名なアーナンダ比丘尊者がアーナンダ比丘和児がお釈迦様にそれは朝早く
もう日の出の前に会って
その人は贅沢三昧の人でしたからね
お釈迦様が森の中で座っているのを見て
横になったからといったら
もう別室に横になったところも
まあ薄い枯れ葉 ちょっとあるだけで
これで人っていうのは生活できるかと
こんな尊い方ではないかと
自分がブッダという名前を聞いただけで驚いちゃって
悟った人がいるんだよと驚いちゃって会いに行ったんですよ
そしたらそういう形で
心配して楽に寝られたんでしょうかと
お釈迦様の答えは 楽に寝るといえば私のようなものだよと
という答えですよ すごい楽に寝られるといえば
私のようなものですよと
心には何の恨みも憎しみも何の汚れもないんだからね
究極に幸福ですよと それでそのアーナンダさんがああ
これが真理です 分かったんですね
だからその人一言葉わからないんだけど
それで喜びに悟るんですよ
真理に納得する あ これが真理だと
それで他の教えっていうのはきれいさっぱり心から落ちてしまう
それっきりでサンマサンカッパ
正しい思考は一筋になるんです
だから預流果っていうのはサンマサンカッパ一筋になるんです
正しい思考 他のことを勉強しないわけじゃない
勉強するんだけど ミッチャーサンカッパになりません
どうしようどうしようというこういう不安定はまるっきりない
しっかりする  ある王様も同じ質問したんですけどね
なんでブッダと弟子たちがね
あれほど輝いているんですかと
あんなに落ち着いて 顔色が美しくて信じられないんだと
何もないんだよと ろくに着るものもないし
食べるものも得られなかったりと
住むところもないし それなのに何だこの落ち着くとこの顔色の美しさと
お釈迦様は同じ答え その人にも言ったんです
やっぱり我々はあれやこれやと過去に悩んだり
将来に悩んだり あれ欲しい
これ欲しいとかね そういう心の不安不満ないんだよと
だから究極に幸福だと
だから究極な幸福っていうのは精神的なことなんです
物質的なことではありません
それはサーラの定義で
で ミッチャーサンカッパ
サンカッパを定義しましたので
ではそこら辺で話を終わりにしたいと思います
まあストーリーはあります
ストーリーは別にね このサーリプッタモクレン尊者の物語で
真理を知りたくて 二人は仲良く仲良しの友人たちで
すごい頭のいい二人でバラモン人でね
出家したんですね だからすごく頭が良かったんだから
いろんな教えを勉強してみたんですよ
それで勉強すればするほど頭がおかしくなる
混乱する 納得いかない
それで先生捨てちゃう
この人はもう納得いかないんだと
別なところに行く それで歩いて回って
もうもう修行中で 最後にある先生のところに泊まったんです
この先生は何も教えません
だから落ち着いたんです
何を聞いても教えません
何についてどんな意見聞いたっても
だからなんかすごい人格なんですよ
なんか訳の分からない人格なんです
それが自分の宗教哲学なんです
例えば その先生ご飯を食べてるとしましょう
先生いかがでしょうか
ご飯はおいしいですか？と
おいしいという意見は出さないんですよ
では まずいんですかね？まずいとは言えないんだと
まずいということはおいしいんで？いえ
おいしいとは言えないんだと
別に喋ってないわけじゃないんですよ
喋ってはいるんだけど
このご飯おいしいです
おいしいとは言えないね
ではまずいんですか？いえ
まずいとは言えないね
ではまあまあですか？と
いえ まあまあとも言えないね
そんな態度です では何の味もないんですか？いえ
何の味もないと言えないね
という態度です うーん
だから怖くて意見って言わないわけでもないんですよ
もしかすると彼がこの意見というのは成り立たないというふうなとこを取っていたみたいんですね
で しかし それもあまり次元がちょっと違う
だから彼が世の中を見てみて
いろんな人はいろんなことを言うんだよ
どちらが正しいか どうやってわかるもんかと
というところでストップしちゃったんですね
それ以上は行かなかった
だから怠け者 仏教から見ればね
もういい加減じゃないかと
いろいろある 誰がわかるもんか
そんな誰が みんなよくあるでしょ
そういう人間も なんか情けない生き方でしょ
あの人はこう言って この人はまあいろいろ言ってるんだからね
まあわかったもんじゃない
これはとても簡単な怠け者の考え方になっちゃうんですね
だからそれそういうふうな人で
結局居心地が悪くない
別に逆らうこともないんだから
賛成することもないし
逆らうこともないし それでその二人がそちらにいたんですけど
納得いったわけじゃないんです
でも納得いかないと言って喧嘩して別れないんですよ
別にその人は意見持ってないんだから
先生は それでブッダに
ブッダの弟子に会って
ある日 見事に落ち着いているのを見てね
話を聞いて まあサーリプッタ尊者かね
まあ最初に悟るんですね
因果法則を聞いてね で
悟って まず次に自分の友達にも教えてあげて
友達も あ なるほど これが真理だと
それで夜中に悟る これでしょうと
答えは一切の問題に すぐ納得いったんですね
今まで悩みに悩んでいたあらゆる問題に対して
この答えだよと ぴったしだと
二人も悟って もう先生のことを心配してたんですね
やっぱりこの先生もこれ探していて諦めちゃったと
あらゆるものについていろいろ意見があって
答え何なのかと これで見つからない
いろんなこといろんなこと言うんだけど
何一つ成り立たない それで終わっちゃったんです
だからこの先生もこれで悩んでるんだから教えてあげましょうと
答えを心配して先生に言ったんですよ
先生 答え見つかりましたと
もう問題ないんだと もう自分の心にひと欠片も
もう不満も悩みも 特にあの
何て言いますか 疑ですね
疑はもうないと で それでもう決めましたと
この偉大なる先生に会いますと
これを発見した先生に会って
さらに完成しなくちゃいけないんだと
あまりにも喜んで あまりにも自信満々で言うと
先生もなんとなく認めたんですよ
やっぱりこの二人はもう答え見つかってるんだと
それで一緒に行きましょうと
言ったら まあ君らがそう言っても
私はインドで有名人だよ
このサンジャヤという人は六識道の六番目なんです
六番目かな 順番はわからない
とにかく一人ですよ インドでは偉大なる先生としてあまりにも知られていて
有名な人でしょうと それでどうやって釈迦さんのところにいて弟子入りできますかと
社会的な立場を考えるとね
これは難しい できないんだと
ですから 君たちは行ってください
それを逆らわなかったんです
だからある意味でいい人ですよ
こちらに弟子入りして
なんたることか そんなこと君たちは行って頑張ってくださいと
私は残りますと いうことで
そちらの弟子の二百五十と書いてますけどね
グループの人々もやっぱり我々も行きますよということで
一緒に行って お釈迦様のところに出家するんですけどね
その出来事でお釈迦様がこの偈を言ったんだと注釈書で言ってますが
本当のことはわかりません
いわゆるサーリプッタ尊者のものエピソードはエピソードで別なもので
そのエピソードに基づいてその偈を唱えた教えたっていうことは
それはわからない これは注釈書でつなげているストーリーですけど
で まあうまく合いますからね
あの人はもうやっぱり意味あるものは勘違いしていて
意味あるものに対しては書けなかったと
だから一生あのまんまでしょう
だからサンジさんは死ぬまであのまんまで何もわからん状態のまんまで死んでしまうでしょうし
その代わりに弟子でいたサーリプッタ
モクレン尊者が仏道に入って一番目
二番目になったんです
仏教を背負って後の世代に広げることまでしたんですね
ブッダの次 サーリプッタとモクレン尊者でしょ
そこまで立った立場へたのに
あの人はただ色識道の一人で
インドの文化から消えてしまったんです
教えまでも 教えもやっと仏教のおかげで一部残っているだけ
どちらには記録されてない
だからまあ 損しましたっていうことでね
だからそれはその個人の話ではなくて
人類がやっていることで
どんな人でも意味あるものは意味がないと思って
意味がないものは意味があると思って
変なところで本当の問題は棚上げにして
別なものに指をさして踏ん張っているんです
いわゆる自分の後ろにほんの小さな水たまりがあるかもしれません
でも 遠く見るとすごい巨大なシンクロの霧を見る
それを見てなんてすごい水ですかと
そちらに行って泳いだり
楽しかったり 遊んだり
水を飲んだりして 思い存分楽しむそうとシンクロを追う
でももともと喉が渇いているんだからね
そばにある水たまりからね
水を飲めば渇き 喉を潤して言うんですか
渇きが消えるのにね それやらないんです
明日幸福になるぞという感じで生きているんです
明日っていうのは永久に今日にならないんだからね
こういうことはおっしゃってます
では 終了します どうもありがとうございます